[Music]
listen to this fairfield california okay
76 year old guy gets pulled over
um suspected of driving under the
influence i think he might be a little
bit buzzed they pull this guy over this
local cops right
they do a breathalyzer already passes
you can go
out of nowhere these other two
detectives roll up and they're like hey
can we get the breathalyzer dna from
that guy because they were tailing him
for some other investigation
they give the dna to these other
detectives and they find out this 76
year old man
has been wanted for murder from some
from two murders up to 40 years ago whoa
wow and these guys been following him
for 40 years number four
in the same car
and they're like can we please
get the dna
from that thing did he did he use it his
mouth was on it yeah can we
we have nothing else
wait or
or did they just start investigating the
murder now after 40 years what happened
is they were actually tailing him
investigating for like a sexual abuse
case that happened that year so he he
was he was just uh suspected of doing
something like now
but he was blowing something else
says the dna
when they processed the actual dna they
found it linked to two other murders
so he's been free like [ __ ] around
doing whatever they don't have your dna
until you [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so that
was just [ __ ] up right there and they
were able to get in the system and they
got a match from a murder 30 years ago
they got a match from a murderer 40
years ago two different ones hey just
because he was driving he [ __ ] won
and then like sleepy old guy yeah this
guy's lived a whole lot that's what i
was gonna say imagine being boys with
the murderer because he's obviously
didn't then don't tell anybody right
he's just kidding but it's like you
found out like 10 years later the 10
years of y'all's friendship you're the
murderer you're just like are you still
friends with him
i would ask so many questions yeah you
would right just insight right yeah yeah
i mean that's my boy who created it
you're already locked up let's just chat
yeah but what if he's not like a cool
murderer like you know like some
murderers are like oh that's gross
like you're one of those [ __ ] like
like what category yeah white blue
category like you kidnapped and tortured
you killed him
golden state killer
yeah yeah you wallet for that yo
like
like an assassin that's a cool murderer
like he killed my brother so i killed
him yeah he won that's cool
that's a chinese murderer though that's
a little different oh you killed my
family i killed you that's old boy oh
boy murderer that's honorable this guy
this guy's murders are not that nature
he i think killed like a woman after he
raped her or something cece white boy
murderer that's white boy murderer yeah
yeah i see what you mean ted bundy style
murder that's a fight when you guys are
talking about your boy as a murderer you
know that's a good question though is
like if you were a murderer
like okay let's say you committed you're
a criminal you commit whatever kind of
crime yeah
which crimes do you tell your friends
about your boys about and which don't
you like i think like rape you probably
don't tell your friends unless all your
friends are rapists yeah that's true
oh now it's a thing like bro
if all your friends are rapists
and you did a rape right
and you don't tell them they're gonna be
so disappointed in you right you're a
poser so you went from you went from 13
to 14 victims and you didn't tell us
so like you know if you're a criminal
like what do you tell like where do you
draw the line like i'm gonna tell my
friends i'm a drug dealer yeah but like
what kind of drugs like is that fentanyl
oh are you killing people or is it weed
yeah because even within crime even
within criminals they have rules and
honor and like they're just oh we don't
like this guy this guy is a [ __ ] kid
toucher we're all going to [ __ ] him up
yeah well that usually has a thing in
prison
right
you like that right oh this guy he's a
he's a crazy like multi like crazy like
national city criminal like he's a
syndicate boss you know it's like whoa
he doesn't even do crime that's how
criminal he is you know he has other
people to do it for him
to tell you that you tell your friends
like if that's dude where do you go to
work what do you do like i never i've
known you for 20 years i don't even know
well i'm a syndicate boss yeah oh that
sounds cool i'm so glad i know you you
know it's like one of those things but
glad i know you know
i think if i like lived a life of crime
i'd be a moral criminal that's what i
would think that's just me i think i'd
be you know higher standing than the
rest of these scumbags it definitely
doesn't sound as cool to be like what
what do you do and then you say i'm the
third strongest rapist in my rape crew
you don't want to break you don't want
to hold that down
you're right
usually like sex crimes oh [ __ ] they're
like the most lowest level poser
that's like the bottom of their you're
like what did you get what are you in
here for you're like i was stealing
underwear you know like yeah it's like
no one's gonna be afraid of you imagine
if you're in a crew full of like all
your boys are a bunch of like molesters
and stuff like you're the guy that's
like oh yeah dude like you're you're a
poser you're like oh dude i got so many
molestations
you're trying to you're trying to be
cool about it you're telling your boys
right and then you're like you're
waiting in the bushes you're like okay
this is gonna be my first one i'm about
to do it but you're like oh [ __ ] i can't
do it you're like
yeah here we go this guy has consensual
sex yeah yeah yeah it's mr consent yeah
yeah
no dude i swear i don't do you know you
know what the craziest thing is too is
like imagine getting away with a murder
for so long that you don't even [ __ ]
think about it anymore yeah oh yeah
it just it just comes out it just comes
out like they probably have to go you're
guilty of this and he goes guilty what
yeah huh who but he's done it twice
right yeah so he's like after the second
one you must feel like i can kill
anybody the first one was in 1980
wow
you think you're good what was the
second one
1994 or something right before tupac
died
that's crazy dude
but that's like saying like y'all still
talking about that
yeah yeah
that's old meals bro oh [ __ ]
out to you
but you know but when you're that old
though it's so far removed i bet you a
lot of people think there's a statue of
limitations oh yeah yeah that's true but
you know because with murder and i think
what rape there is right but not only is
every state there is yeah but like
murder there's no statute of limitations
cosby bro they say this [ __ ] was like 70
years ago and there's
you know so yes some um but like yeah if
there's a sexual limitation or i mean if
they don't think there is one they may
just be like oh yeah no i did it
oh yeah you know yeah i i did it like
you said you're talking to your boys and
then like murder it was 20 years ago hey
remember tanya is like oh yeah i killed
her yeah sorry sorry what now listen to
this man so yeah there are states where
there is no statute of limitations for
rape uh alabama alaska arizona no
statute arkansas the statute of
limitations for abe is six years
so after six years you can't call it
anymore you can't i guess you can't be
tried criminal criminal i feel like six
years is so short i feel like even the
punishments for rape are like
like two years connecticut's five years
uh statute of limitations why not what's
crazy is that in hip-hop there's some
like gangster hip-hop like rap artists
that feel like it's like in five minutes
it's over with yeah go and make a song
right after like yo i just caught a body
oh in california it's it's a rate for
rape and sexual assault is 10 years whoa
that's [ __ ] wild what the [ __ ] if you
don't report it or like file for it
within the 10 years it's done i'm sure
there's like little other details that
make it still be a case but like i'm
gonna start a company for all the places
where this statute of limitations exists
and then um i'll do my own justice if
they didn't get it
your own justice yeah i'll do my own uh
style yeah vigilante style and then i'll
have a menu we're gonna go around raping
rapists yep i'll have that uh would you
like to get i won't do it but i'll find
a guy that will or a woman and then um
i'll have just straight murder or like
something like that i think this is how
gangs are actually formed because
protection you get paid you could pay
them be like hey can you like torture
this guy for me or like yeah
okay toad by the way yeah i'm looking
for
so pleasant what's your menu can i see
your menu first
waterboarding you're still doing that
i thought that was illegal okay
there's a sale on waterboarding for
christmas that's actually pretty good
you're looking at a menu you refer a
friend you get 20 off specials bogo
because remember um
buy one head get one of it off because
remember jaw rule
he had a crew called murder inc it's
actually based off of a real group
called murder incorporated back in the
day where i think it was like bug not
bugsy seagull um
basically it was a bunch of lobsters it
was mobster guys but it wasn't like
i don't know if they were italian i
think they were like jewish irish or
like guys that couldn't join the italian
mob like ira kind of people but they
were like well because i think you have
to be like i uh italian you have to be
sicilian of yeah they gotta trace you
back these guys were like uh still like
you know like down for their [ __ ] and
but they just formed their own like
organization called murder inc and then
like they um they collaborated but they
were like an assassination group for
like these different [ __ ] mobsters
that was really a nail on their head
with the name i know right murder
incorporated
that's hiding we're gonna be murdering
so
but they're like yeah then they just
they just [ __ ] did all these hit jobs
for all these mobs and i'm like that's
so cool but what if we can do that like
a vigilante group for people that didn't
get justice because the california
justice system the 18
so i'm gonna kill two birds with one
stone uh another reason why korea's
number one is because of korean dramas
and there's one called taxi driver which
basically took what you just said about
revenge really and they go around so
there's people that got like assaulted
raped sexually assaulted or like
wrongfully accused or like a corporation
took their property whatever it was like
dexter but korean style yeah and it's a
group so they have of course you know
every group now requires a hacker so
they have a hacker and then they have a
guy who's you know a physical specimen
that can fight everywhere it's and then
he drives a taxi tire
then don't you have to have some kind of
like a a court system to determine that
person is not no
dude we're like cancel culture if you
accuse you're done
yeah we we all we believe everybody you
know like off-brand old school like a
cop radio that they listen into like
yeah they hear all these dispatchers
it barely works we found one
evidence is is unimportant so you gotta
state your case and be believable that's
it
it's feelings it's all feelings so
feeling yeah if a girl comes to me
crying
game over yeah dude that's that's all i
need is crying and this is what happened
i believe her a thousand percent we
believe all women bro you're gonna
believe all women mafia yeah believe oh
man
yeah and if a guy comes to me crying
saying he got [ __ ] up and he needs
revenge i'ma [ __ ] him up
that's a twist
[Music]
you
[Music]